hugs and smiles of relief 85-year-old
Alberto fimor leaves prison in Lima
flanked by his children K and Kenji and
welcomed by a crowd of supporters Peru
constitutional Court reinstated the
former president's pardon denied since
2017 by the interamerican court for
human rights judges say the
international court has no authority
over fim Mor's fate and ordered his
release on human itarian
grounds I am happy and thankful because
the Constitutional courts ensured our
sovereignty prevailed by reinstating the
2017 pardon and ensuring his prompt
release the former president had been
serving a 25-year sentence for the
extrajudicial killings of 25 peruvians
including a child he has not paid any of
the more than $50 million owed in
reparations to families of the victims
instead he spent spent the past 16 years
maintaining his
innocence the road has been long and
painful for our family we want to start
over there's no place for hatred in our
hearts the government supported the
Constitutional Court's order even though
it contradicts the international
ruling compliance with the rulings of
the Constitutional Court does not ignore
our obligations derived by International
treaties and the interamerican system
for human rights we ratify our firm
adherance to the American convention on
human
rights supporters say they've waited a
long time for this day they credit fuimo
with the defeat of the Rebel group
shining path and saving the economy from
collapse in the 1990s Alberto fimi
Alberto fujimori built schools highways
hospitals around the country and brought
us peace he was Peru's best president
this is the end of another chapter for
fuimo but on Thursday a new trial Begins
for the torture and killing of six
Farmers by fim Mor's death
squad a prosecutor once him kept under
house arrest during these Court
proceedings which families of the victim
say offer another chance for justice to
be served Marana Sanchez aljas
Lima make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaer